splatoon has been one of nintendo's most
surprising new franchises in recent
years a wild combination of shooter and
zone control in a stylish multiplayer
package now with switch well established
and extremely successful splatoon 3
looks to bring back the inky magic
here's everything we know about splatoon
3 so far including the release date
multiplayer details and what to expect
from the single player campaign mode
platoon 3 features a few changes for the
series the most obvious of which is the
setting splatoon 3 takes place in an
arid desert wasteland known as the
splatlands at the heart of the desert is
a new hub city called splattsville where
players will gather between matches the
story mode appears to be mystery themed
this time around the series itself
focuses on a battle between the inklings
and the octarians after global warming
supposedly caused humans to go extinct
after the inklings won the great turf
war against the octarians which occurred
100 years or so before the first game
the inklings created the sport you play
in the splatoon games in order to
commemorate the inkling victory in the
first game you stopped the theft of the
zapfish by the octarians which helped
power the other major city in the series
inkopolis the second game featured the
player character rescuing splatfest
champion cali from being brainwashed by
the octarians splatoon 3 is set a year
and a half after that game as you once
again face off against the octarians who
now appear to have mutated you'll do
battle with the octarian army whose
members are covered in hair for some
reason
return of the mammalians sees your
inkling team up with agent 3 and your
sidekick small fry where you'll learn
about the fuzzy ooze and hopefully
finally get some answers about just what
the heck happened to turn squids into
kids and where all the humans went the
game will also take you to new locations
like alternia a large snowy land as well
as a dark mirrored city nintendo
promises the story will serve as the
epic finale to the series that splatoon
has been building to over the last few
games
the trailer for the game confirmed the
series signature 4v4 turf war mode will
return in splatoon 3. but this time
there will be new stages set in the
wilds around splatsville nintendo also
teased there will be new moves and
weapons as well such as a new bow and a
crab shaped auto bomb it also appears
that players will now launch themselves
onto the map from the air rather than
spawning in at designated locations this
could have big ramifications for the
late stages of matches if it lets
players land in contested areas in order
to spray down their ink before the timer
runs out quickly like the previous games
splatoon 3 will feature splat fests
large scale social events that the
community settles by choosing team
colors this time though the splat fest
consists of not two but three choices
players will fight in a 4v4 turf war
style match for the first round and then
convert to a tri-color second round whoa
three teams fight at the same time the
first place team will start in the
center while the other two teams will
start on opposing sides giving the
leader more of a challenge to defend
their turf nintendo has also confirmed
the return of salmon run this time with
a video showing its next wave this
version will once again feature
cooperative play as you work with
teammates to take out the enemies in
wave based rounds you'll have to take on
new large-scale bosses like slam and lid
a ufo that creates protective barriers
and big shot a muscly salmonid that
fires cannonballs a massive king salmon
called kahunza shows up as the final
challenge before you complete a stage
and you'll have to take it down with a
special egg cannon nintendo has also
said a big run mode will have samonitz
invade the city itself as a special
event that occurs every few months
finally splatoon 3 will add a new card
based game called table turf battle the
1v1 competitive mode has you place cards
with geometric shapes similar to touch
aminos on a board your goal is to claim
territory by placing blocks on your own
color on the board similar to the main
splatoon objective each player will get
a starter deck and there will be 150
cards to collect in all speaking of
gameplay though character customization
is also an important part of splatoon's
combat you can unlock new fashion
options including headgear clothing and
shoes from various vendors that
equipment comes with passive boosts to
certain abilities and you can swap out
abilities using a particular npc if you
just want a certain look aside from your
personal style you can also customize
your locker with accessories and your
favorite fashions which will serve as
the way you view recent opponents and
friends mailboxes littered throughout
the city will let you submit drawings
and you can snap selfies of your squid
kid with a photo mode
[Music]
all that being said multiplayer is the
foundation of the splatoon series and is
once again the central focus in splatoon
3. as we mentioned earlier the series
4v4 turf 4 mode is returning this time
with entirely new stages moves and
weapons including a brand new bow as we
mentioned before that can fire ink shot
arrows called the stinger and a melee
weapon with a charged shot called the
splatana it also appears some old
specials are returning in splatoon 3
after being cut from the series second
installment in the reveal trailer one
character can be seen firing a modified
inkzooka a special move from splatoon 1.
nintendo has also confirmed new specials
like the tactic cooler that dispenses
buff providing beverages the wave
breaker that pulses and marks opponents
and the reef slider that charges
straight into enemies charge into
opponents who need a good splat you'll
also have a few new moves in your
arsenal like the squid surge to burst up
walls and the squid roll to pop out of
the ink the multiplayer will launch with
12 maps and more are said to be coming
in three post launch updates you can
familiarize yourself by testing weapons
in test range explore maps in recon mode
and review highlights of matches
nintendo announced a large-scale dlc
plan that will see splatoon 3 be
supported for up to two years after
launch first and foremost nintendo will
create a new clothing catalog every
three months for two years after the
game releases new weapons will also
release with these categories too
because if you're gonna buy new clothing
you might as well get new ways to be
your enemies as well on top of the
standard ranked mode post launch updates
will add a high ranking x battle mode
along with league battles all of these
updates will be free however nintendo
also confirmed a paid dlc similar in
size to splatoon 2's octo expansion dlc
that will come at some point after the
game's release
as a premier nintendo property you'll
need a switch to play splatoon 3.
additionally you'll need to have a
nintendo switch online subscription to
play splatoon 3 online individual
memberships cost four dollars for one
month eight dollars for three months and
20 for one year while an annual family
plan runs for 35 dollars and covers up
to eight nintendo accounts across
multiple systems nintendo also has
recently added a switch online expansion
pass tier including bonuses like the
genesis and n64 classic catalogs along
with an included expansion for animal
crossing new horizons nintendo has not
outlined whether we'll be regularly
adding game dlc as a switch online
expands past perk but if so we may see
some bonuses included for splatoon 3. to
lend credence to this possibility
nintendo has already added splatoon 2's
story dlc as a bonus to the expansion
pass tier
[Music]
splatoon 3 releases on september 9th and
is up for pre-order at best buy amazon
gamestop target walmart and the nintendo
eshop all for 60 dollars if you
pre-order at walmart you get an adorable
squid plush for free and you can choose
between bright blue neon green neon pink
and neon purple for your new plush
friend best buy gives you a free key
chain and gamestop gets you a sticker
sheet in addition to all this a special
splatoon 3 switch oled was recently
released that special switch includes a
special ink splatter paint job on the
dock and joy-con controllers if all of
that isn't enough splatoon for you
nintendo also announced splatoon 3
amiibos including a yellow inkling a
blue octarian and small fry all of which
will arrive this holiday though no
specific release date has been announced
scanning these amiibos will net you
their gear combinations that they wear
in the game as well as other exclusive
gear and you'll be able to get them
individually or in a 3-pack and that's
everything you need to know before the
release of splatoon 3. now
get inking
[Music]